SESSION ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM. SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS OF THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. DEGREE ARE
CURRY. ARAMBULA BARRICADE HAN
BENNETT. BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
BOERNER HORVATH BONTA. BRIAN
BURKE. CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN. CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON. GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LIII LEVINE. LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN SUSHI AS
AARON QUINN O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH
STONE TEAM BALLOT THERE AS THE
APPROVED VIA VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER. H.
PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR
ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN. IMAM YASIR
KHAN IMAM YES SIR. IN THE NAME
OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS THE
MOST MERCIFUL. YOU KNOW EACH OF
THE MEMBERS OF THIS STATE
ASSEMBLY. YOU HAVE GIVEN EACH
DIFFERENT GIFTS BUT TOGETHER
THEY MAY ACHIEVE YOUR PURPOSE
AND BRING ABOUT LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. YOU HAVE
CALLED THEM FOR IN DIFFERENT
PLACES AND ASSEMBLED THEM IN
THIS CHAMBER TO SERVE THIS
GREAT STATE AND SHAPE ITS
FUTURE. GIVE THEM VISION ROOTED
IN FAITH. ATTENTIVELY LISTENING
TO THE NEEDS OF THE TIMES OF
DISCERNING HEARTS TO MAKE RIGHT
JUDGEMENTS I MEAN. THANK YOU
BYE YES SIR WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS TO REMAIN REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
ROBERTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. HAND OVER HEART. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED- ISRAEL. THANK
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
SUBMISSIONS ARE MEMBERS YOU
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SEASON WITH AT NINE AM THE
AUDIBLE REBEKAH BARRICADE IN
SYSTEM SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE
ASSEMBLY PRESIDING CHIEF OF
SUPERCAPACITOR INCORPORATED ON
THE READING WILL CALL THE ROLL
CALL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN WITH A CORPORAL THE
ASSEMBLY MOTION CARRY TIME NINE
AM USES REPORT IMPORT DIRECTED
SERGEANT ARMS CLOSED DOORS
BRING IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
NINE TWELVE AM ASSIST REPORT
EMPLOYEE PARKING HANDLER
QUANTITIES AND THE PRESENT ROLL
CALL WAS COMPLETED FOLLOWING
ANSWER TO THE NAMES
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA PARA QUE
HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DAVIES FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GREAT GRAYSON
HOLDEN THIS RAMOS MOVES AND MR
LARA SECOND SAID THE READING.
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
M. IS
RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
CALDERON MULLIN ROBERT RIVAS
CORK AND HOLDEN TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. THERE ARE LETTERS AT
THE DESK BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BENNETT CONCERNING AB EIGHT TO
FOUR BENNETT AND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ CONCERNING AB
SEVEN RODRIGUEZ PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY TWO C. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
PRINT THESE LETTERS IN THE
JOURNAL. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RETURN
ITEM SIXTY ONE AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SIX JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
TO THE SENATE FOR FURTHER
ACTION WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THE RULES AND WITHDRAW THE
FOLLOWING BILLS FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND PLACE THEM ON THE
THIRD READING FILE. AB ONE
FIGHT I'M SORRY. CORRECTION S.
B. ONE FIVE FIVE. SB ONE SIX
TWO. S. B. ONE SIX THREE. M. S.
B.'S. ONE SIX FIVE THREE ONE
SEVEN SEVEN INCLUSIVE. MISTER
FOR PURPOSE- WE WITHHOLD IN
ASKING SINISTRAL PROBLEM MR
FLOOR IS WITHHOLDING MS REYES
MOVES AND MISTER CHOW SECONDS
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL MAN.
PROCEDURAL VOTE IS RACES ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE IN MISTER FLORA
NO. IS RACES ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MR FLOOR A NO VOTE ON THE
RULES SUSPENSION. THIS IS
PROCEDURAL. WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF ICE FORTY THREE KNOWS
THIRTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MS RAISE YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
WITHDRAW FROM ENROLLMENT AB SIX
SIX SIX CHIU AND AB ONE FIVE
SIX EIGHT EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
COMMITTEE AND ORDER THE BILL'S
RETURNED TO THE SENATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH A WITH YOUR- AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE ITEM ONE EIGHTY ONE
SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX GONZALEZ TO
THE INACTIVE FILE. THE CLERK
WILL NOTE. MEMBERS WE HAVE
GUESTS WITH US TODAY IN THE
ASSEMBLY. UNDER GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS WE HAVE A NEW
MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY MR GIVES
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
VERY SPECIAL INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS MEMBERS- HONORED
TODAY TO INTRODUCE ONE OF OUR
NEWEST MEMBERS OF OUR FAMILY TO
THIS CHAMBER. ASSEMBLY WOMAN
MIA BONTA REPRESENTING THE
EIGHTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
MIA HAS A REMARKABLE
EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND. SHE'S
EARNED HER MASTER'S DEGREE OF
EDUCATION FROM HARVARD AND HER
JD FROM YALE LAW SCHOOL. AS THE
EDUCATOR ADVOCATE MEDIA HAS
SPENT HER CAREER. FIGHTING FOR
STUDENTS AND WORKING FAMILIES.
AS CEO. OAKLAND PROMISE AND
PRESIDENT ALAMEDA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT MEDIA FOX FOUR
ON THE FRONTLINE TO DISRUPT THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE AS A
MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MIA BONTA CONTINUES HER LIFE
LARA HER LIFELONG FIVE EQUITY
IN THE AREAS OF EDUCATION.
HEALTH JUSTICE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
THE NEWEST MEMBER TO OUR FAMILY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN MIA BONTA. MS
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU SO MUCH THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON FOR THAT WARM
INTRODUCTION IT IS AN HONOR TO
BE WITH YOU ALL TODAY
REPRESENTING ALAMEDA OAKLAND
AND SAN LEANDRO EIGHTEEN TO
SOMETHING THAT ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT- IT IS BEEN A WORLD
ANOTHER JOURNEY TO BE ABLE TO
GET HERE. I AM SO HONORED TO BE
ABLE TO SERVE WITH YOU ALL I
SEEING YOU IN ACTION FOR MANY
YEARS AND I'M SO GLAD TO BE A
PART OF THE TEAM AND TO
REPRESENT THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS
WE ARE GOING TO BE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE PASS AND
RETAIN. YEAH WE ARE GOING TO BE
TAKING UP MS REYES THE MEASURE
THIS IS FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR.
AB. SIX FIVE FOUR. AND THE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FIFTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAY AS AN ACTIVE IN
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY IN THE
CLEARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TECH VICTIM MEDIALLY. THIS RARE
FEMALE. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT
EIGHTY SIX FIVE FOUR WHICH IS
THE CLEAN UP TO MY PREVIOUS
MEASURE EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE
WHICH FOCUSED ON THE BASIC
STEPS EMPLOYERS MUST TAKE TO
CONTROL WORK SITE SPECIFIC
EXPOSURES TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN. CLEAN UP TO THIS
MEASURES THE CENTRAL TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA SO THAT WE CAN
MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. RECENT AMENDMENTS
REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION. AND EVEN
MOVED THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND OTHERS OF THE OPPOSITION
COALITION TO A SUPPORT POSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS REYES.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. A COUPLE OF NARAL.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. THIS TAKES
FIFTY FOUR ON THE URGENCY ALL
MEMBERS OF THAT ABOUT.
ALL
MEMBERS FOR A RESERVE THE.
MISS
RASK MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO SENATE THIRD
READING. IS THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE. BEGINNING WITH
FILE ITEM IN FILE ORDER. SIXTY
SIX. SENATE BILL FOR THIRTY
TWO. AND THE CORPORATE. SENATE
BILL FOUR THIRTY TWO BY CENTER
BY CAL SKI ENACTED IN THE
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS.
THAT COULD CHEN YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISS READER THIS BILL
IS BACK IN EUROPE'S I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
DR CHEN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO AMEND THAT
STATEMENT OF THIS BILL IS BACK
IN CONCURRENCE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. IT'S ACTUALLY NOT ON
THE CONCURRENCE FILESERVE OKAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
MEDICAL THAT'S THE TICKET.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. CARCLUB THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OF. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VETERANS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE SIDE
OF A. WELL. CLOSE ROLE TYLER I
SEE ONE KNOWS ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE GOING TO
PASS RETAIN UP OUT OF SIXTY
SEVEN AND. SIXTY EIGHT. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY NINE SENATE
BILL SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR AND THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR BY CENTER
GLAZER AND OTHERS INCLUDING
STATE GOVERNMENT. IS RIVAS YOU
MAIL BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SB SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
WOULD ENSURE THAT NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES UNDER
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE HAVE
THE SAME FLEXIBILITY DURING A
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY AS
THE STATE'S OWN DEPARTMENT AND
WORK FORCE. NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS DELIVER ESSENTIAL
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIA. ON
BEHALF OF AND FUNDED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AT THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC TEMAS
DEMONSTRATED MANY IMPORTANT ON
PROFIT PROGRAMS CAN BE
DISRUPTED BY A DISASTER OR
OTHER EMERGENCY THIS CAN IMPACT
THE NONPROFIT'S ABILITY TO
SERVE ITS COMMUNITY BY LIMITING
ITS PROGRAMS AND CASH FLOW.
RECOGNIZING THAT NONPROFIT
SERVICE PROVIDERS WERE THE
BACKBONE OF THE SERVICES SUPPLY
CHAIN. AND RISK SHUTTING DOWN
PERMANENTLY WITHOUT CONTINUED
SUPPORT SEVERAL COUNTIES
IMPLEMENTED POLICIES TO GRANT
THEIR NONPROFIT PARTNERS
FLEXIBILITY. THIS ALLOWED THEM
TO ALTER THE TERMS OF THEIR
CONTRACTS AS LONG AS GOALS OF
THE CONTRACTS WERE STILL MAD.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
ENSURE THAT SIMILAR FLEXIBILITY
IS EMBEDDED INTO THE STATE'S
NONPROFIT CONTRACTS IT'S
SUPPORTED BY MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS RIVAS CA NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CARPOOL
OF MORAL. IS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRABLE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ARE ALL TIED UP.
HIGHS FIFTY EIGHT. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. YOUR. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SENATE BILL.
TWO ELEVEN. CORKERY SENATE BILL
TWO ELEVEN BY SENATOR UMBERG
IMMACULATE TO ATTORNEYS MR
STONE EMAIL PRINT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS
THE ANNUAL BAR DUES BILL IN
THIS BILL WE SET THE TO DO'S
RATE FOR ATTORNEYS TO PAY INTO
THE BARS WHICH THIS YEAR IS THE
SAME AS LAST YEAR BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE BAR IS PERFORMING ITS
FUNCTIONS AS A PROTECTOR OF THE
PUBLIC INTEREST AND- THE
ATTORNEY DISCIPLINE ISSUES AS
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN OF HIM COME
TO THE FORE. THIS BILL IS I WAS
PUSHING THE STATE BAR TO DO A
BETTER JOB WITH WITH ATTORNEY
DISCIPLINE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR STONE.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OVER THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- THERE. CORP
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AS
FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES WERE TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM SEVENTY ONE. I GOT
IT. THERE WE ARE GOING. TO PASS
TEMPORARILY. ON FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY TWO. THE BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE. SB SIX
NINETY FOUR. AND THE CORPORATE
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY FOUR BY
CENTER BRADFORD AND ABILITY TO
FIRE PREVENTION MR HOLDEN YOUR
MAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SB SIX NINETY FOUR IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE THAT
CREATES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CONSERVATION CORPS MEMBERS AS
WELL AS FORMERLY INCARCERATED
FIREFIGHTERS TO WORK IN
WILDFIRE MITIGATION. THIS BILL
REQUIRES INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES TO REPORT ON THEIR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT EFFORTS
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES OF SKILLED WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF PEOPLE WORKING IN
WILDFIRE MITIGATION THIS BILL
WILL HELP FILL THAT SHORTAGE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR HOLDEN C.
NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
WELL WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE-
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALTERNATIVE
BUT I FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MISS REYES
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE ITEM
ONE OH FIVE SB THREE FOUR NINE
AMBERG TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
THE CLERK WILL NOT. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW
AB SIX SEVEN ZERO CALDERON FROM
ENROLLMENT AND RETURN THE BILL
TO THE SENATE FOR FURTHER
ACTION. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MEMBERS
BACK INTO FILE ORDER. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR S. B.
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR. IN THE
CORKERY SENATE BILL FIVE EIGHTY
FOUR BY SOONER JONES AND ACTIVE
IN THE FOSTER CARE THIS RUBIO
YOUR MAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
WERE REQUIRE RESOURCE FAMILIES
ALSO KNOWN AS FOSTER FAMILIES
TO BE TRAINED ON HOW TO CARE
FOR FOSTER YOUTH WHO ARE AT
RISK OF EXPERIENCING CHILD
LABOR TRAFFICKING IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE PROTECT THESE
YOUTH FROM BECOMING A TURK ARE
TERRIFYING STATISTIC. FOSTER
PARENTS MUST BE PROVIDED WITH
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING THAT
FOCUSES ON THE DIVERSE NEEDS OF
FOSTER YOUTH INCLUDING THE
PREVENTION OF CHILD LABOR
TRAFFICKING. THE EXPANDED
TRAINING PROVIDED BY THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE FOSTER PARENTS ARE
EQUIPPED AND EDUCATED TO CARE
FOR FOSTER YOUTH THAT ARE AT
RISK. FOR ALL FORMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING INCLUDING CHILD
LABOR TRAFFICKING. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. DAVIS RUBIO SENIOR
SESSION DEBATE LOCAL APPAREL.
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
BUT IS THAT A VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLLTIDE WHAT ICE FIFTY
EIGHT ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE
SB SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT CORKERY
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG IMMACULATE
INTO LAND USE HISTORY RESCUE
MAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ARE EXPANDING HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IS THE SINGLE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAY TO BRIDGE THE WEALTH GAP IN
LIFT FAMILIES OUT OF CYCLE OF.
POVERTY HERE IN CALIFORNIA YES
HOME PRICES THE CONTINUED
INCREASE MANY RENTERS OF ALL
INCOME LEVELS BUT ESPECIALLY
THOSE OF LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME VIEW HOMEOWNERSHIP AS AN
UNATTAINABLE GOAL TRULY
ADDRESSING OUR STATE'S HOME
OWNERSHIP. CRISIS WILL REQUIRE
US TO RE EVALUATE OUR EXISTING
LAWS AND PROGRAMS AIMED AT
INCREASING THE AVAILABILITY OF
HOUSING AT LARGE. ONE SUCH
PROGRAM IS THE DENSITY BONUS
LAW WHICH HAS BEEN AMENDED
MULTIPLE TIMES LAST FORTY
YEARS. IN RESPONSE TO IT. IN
RESPONSE TO EVOLVING HOUSING
CONDITIONS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE MEASURE HERE- THIS
AFTERNOON AMENDS THIS BODY OF
LAW TO SURE THAT NONPROFITS
SPECIFICALLY THAT- ARE
DEDICATED TO PROVIDING
HOMEOWNERSHIP SOLUTIONS ARE
ABLE TO PURCHASE FOR STILL
UNITS IN AN APPROVED- THE
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT. THIS
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION WILL
ALLOW THESE NONPROFITS TO
LEVERAGE THE DENSITY BONUS LAW
TO SERVE FAMILIES WITH LIMITED
INCOME. A DUST- INSURING THAT
WE POVIDE AN ADDITIONAL AVENUE
IN MAKING POSSIBLE THE DREAM OF
OWNERSHIP FOR ALL THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED SOME BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT TODAY RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU MISS BECAUSE-
THANK YOU MISS RIVAS. C.
NOTIFICATION AVE. GLOBAL OF
MORAL. THE SERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF.
RESERVE A. FOR TWELVE CLOSE
ROLL TIDE AT I. SIXTY NO ZERO.
DEVONSHIRE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVENTY SIX SB FIVE SIX
FOUR HICKORY SENATE BILL FIVE
SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR T. EASY
AN ACCOLADE IN HOSPITALS MR LOW
YOUR MAILBOX THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
SB FIVE SIXTY FOUR ASSISTS WITH
SEISMIC SAFETY COMPLIANCE
EFFORTS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU WHICH LO SI
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. FOR WELL
OVER THE ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A-
BURKE WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FIFTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. PASS RETAIN
UP OUT OF SEVENTY SEVEN PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT PASSED RETAIN A
PROBLEM SEVENTY NINE THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY.
SB THREE TWENTY SIX CORKERY
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY SIX BY
CENTER PAN AND OTHERS
IMMACULATE IN THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE DR WOULD YOU MAIL BUT-
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS OF THE ACA TO STAND
IN CALIFORNIA EVEN IF THE ACA
IS REPEALED. I'M TALKING ABOUT
PROTECTIONS AGAINST PRE
EXISTING CONDITION EXCLUSIONS-
THE REQUIREMENT THE PLANS HAVE
TO SELL YOU A POLICY REGARDLESS
OF YOUR HEALTH STATUS AND RENEW
THE POLICY NO MATTER WHAT KIND
OF ILLNESS YOU MAY HAVE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH. RESTRICTIONS ON
PLANS FROM INCREASING PREMIUMS
WHEN YOU GET SICK ENSURING THAT
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS ARE
COVERED BY HEALTH PLANS. UNDER
THE EXISTING LAW TODAY IF THE
ACA'S REPEALED SO WITH THESE
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTIONS.
THE SO ALSO WOULD BE THESE
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN IMPLEMENTING THESE INSURANCE
MARKET REFORMS AND THERE IS NO
REASON TO TIE OUR LAW. TRY OUR
LOG IN THIS WAY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR ABOUT. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOULD SAY NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. LOCAL OF MORAL. IS
THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY ONE THROUGH EIGHTY
THREE PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FOUR. PASS TO
RETAIN A FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY SIX SB
EIGHT TWENTY THREE. CORPORATE
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY THREE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND
ACCORDING TO PUBLIC HEALTH DR
WOULD YOU MAKE AN ALBUM THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH OMNIBUS
BILL CONTAINS THREE NON
CONVERTED ON NON CONTROVERSIAL
PROVISIONS IT JUST KIND OF
FIXES A FEW THINGS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD. C.
NOTIFICATION DEBATE. CLICK WELL
OVERALL. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENT OF A. WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE I FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN SB FOUR OH
NINE FOUR CORRECT SENATE BILL
FOUR OH NINE BY CENTER
CABALLERO AN ACCOLADE IN THE
PHARMACY. MR LOW YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES. SB FOUR
NINE HELPS TO ASSIST WITH
CLINICAL LABORATORY TESTING
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MITCHELL- SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLARK WELL OVERALL.
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESERVE A- CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY KNOWS
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. PASS
A RETAINER PROBLEMS EIGHTY
EIGHT AND EIGHTY NINE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETY S. B. TWO
THIRTY ONE. IN THE CORPORATION
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY ONE BY
SOONER MCGUIRE AND OTHERS CAN
ACTUALLY TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION. DR WOULD YOU
MAY IT OPEN. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB TWO
THIRTY ONE WOULD ALLOW CALTRANS
TO TRANSFER THE BLUES BEACH OR
THE CHADBOURNE GULCH BEACH AS
IT'S CALLED PROPERTY TO A
NONPROFIT AGENCY ORGANIZED BY
THE ROUND VALLEY INDIAN TRIBES
SURE WOULD VALLEY BAND OF POMO
INDIANS AND THE COOK CARE UT
VALLEY BENT DOWN TO POMO
INDIANS. IN FEBRUARY TWENTY
NINETEEN MISTER WOOD BAND OF
POMO INDIANS ROUND VALLEY
INDIAN TRIBES AND COYOTE VALLEY
BAND OF POMO INDIANS FORMED A
FORMAL WORKING GROUP TO
ADVOCATE FOR JOINT OWNERSHIP OF
WITH A HISTORICAL STEWARDS OF
THE LAND WHICH REPRESENTS BOTH
SACRED AND CULTURAL
SIGNIFICANCE. THE LAN WILL
SOLELY BE WILL FOR THE LAND
MUST BE SOLELY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CULTURAL
PROTECTION THERE'LL BE NO
ABILITY TO DEVELOP THE PROPERTY
FOR COMMERCIAL REASONS. PUBLIC
BEACH ACCESS WILL ALSO BE
MAINTAINED AND THERE MAY BE
SOME CLOSURE OF THE LAND TO
PROTECT SOME CULTURAL
RESOURCES. RETURNING THIS LAND
OF THE TRIBES NOT ONLY THE
RIGHT THING TO DO BUT WILL ALSO
LEAD TO PROPER STEWARDSHIP AND
HISTORICAL PRESERVATION HAVE AN
ACTIVE LAND MANAGER WILL BE A
BENEFIT TO US ALL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
THOUGH. THANK YOU DR WORK. AND
I APPLAUD YOUR FIRST PLACE
BASQUE SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THERE IS WHERE FILE ITEM NINETY
ONE SB. FOUR HUNDRED. CORKERY
SENATE BILL FOUR HUNDRED BY
CIVIL JONES ACTUALLY THE
HOMELESS CHILDREN AND USE.
THREE OF US YOU MAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER SB FOUR HUNDRED
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT TO SCHOOLS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON
ASSISTING HOMELESS STUDENTS.
ADDITIONALLY SB FOUR HUNDRED
INSURERS LOCAL LIAISONS COMPLY
WITH FEDERAL LAW BY PROVIDING
HOMELESS YOUTH WITH REFERRALS
TO EXISTING LOCAL ESSENTIAL
SERVICES. THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR FOUND THAT MOST ELEAZAR
IT SURVEYED WERE UNAWARE OF THE
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER FEDERAL
LAW TO ASSIST HOMELESS YOUTH
AND THAT TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
THOUSAND HOMELESS YOUTH COULD
BE GOING ON IDENTIFIED AN
UNASSISTED. RECENT AMENDMENTS
REDUCE COST PRESSURES AND MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO CONFORM
WITH FEDERAL LAW I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MATH RIVAS. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. BURKE WELL
OVER THERE ALL. BETTER SERVICE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS FOR ESERVER. WELL
CLOSER ALL TIVER. HIGHS SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WANT TO PASS A RETAINER
BALANCE NINETY TWO NINETY THREE
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NINETY FOUR. SB. SEVENTY SIX
RECOVERY SENATE BILL SEVENTY
SIX BY CENTER NIELSEN AND I
BELIEVE IN STATE EMPLOYEES
MITHRAS YOUR AVAILABLE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY
PRESENT S. B. IN SEVENTY SIX BY
SENATOR NIELSEN WHICH ALLOWS
EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES TO REQUEST
ARBITRATION IS THE NEXT STEP IN
THE GRIEVANCE PROCESS THIS BILL
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN ALL COMMITTEES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS REYES.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE AT
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM. NINETY FIVE. S. B. EIGHTY
FOUR. CORKERY SENATE BILL
EIGHTY FOUR BY CENTER HER TADO
AND ACCOLADES OIL AND GAS WELLS.
MISTER CELIS YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL EIGHTY
FOUR OF THE OFFICE AND HER TADO
THIS PROVIDES TRANSPARENCY
AROUND ORPHAN WELL REMEDIATION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LIVE A-
THANK YOU MICHELLE. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CORPORAL.
IS THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NINETY SIX SB TWO OH SIX
CORKERY SENATE BILL TWO OH SIX
BY SENATE MCGUIRE AND OTHERS
IMMACULATE IN THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT THIS YOUR FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB TWO
OH SIX WILL OUT TEMPORARY AND
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS TO BE
INCLUDED. IN THE PROTECTIONS
PROVIDED UNDER THE FIREFIGHTER
BILL OF RIGHTS. THESE PROJECTS
ARE CURRENTLY UNDER LAW
CURRENTLY ONLY APPLY TO FULL
TIME FIREFIGHTERS SEASONAL
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE FRONT LINES
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS FROM
DOZEN FIRES. THAT CONTINUE TO
RAVAGE OUR STATE. IT IS PAST
TIME FOR THE STATE TO PROTECT
THEM AS THEY PROTECT US I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MUCH. FOR SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE BURKE WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
IS THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. ASCERTAINABLE I'M
NINETY SEVEN THIS IS FILE ITEM
NINETY EIGHT SB TWO FORTY EIGHT
CORKERY. SENATE BILL TWO FORTY
EIGHT BY CENTER BATES AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES MR
LACKEY THEY OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS SO I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB TWO FORTY
EIGHT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR.
PATRICIA BATES UNDER CURRENT
LAW A SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR
COMMITTED TO THE STATE HOSPITAL
FOR AN INDETERMINATE TERM.
LATER RECEIVES A NEW PRISON
COMMITMENT IS RESTRAINED BY CDC
OURS AND SBP AFTER SERVING
THEIR NEW PRISON TERM. THIS
GIVES NESTLE P. A SECOND BITE
OF THE APPLE BY ALLOWING THEM
TO RELITIGATE THEIR ORIGINAL SB
COMMITMENT AFTER COMMITTING A
CRIME ALL IN THE STATE HOSPITAL.
SB TWO FORTY EIGHT CLOSES THIS
LOOPHOLE. AND IN THE SEXUALLY
VIOLENT PREDATOR ACT. BY
REQUIRING AN S. B. B. TO
COMPLETE THEIR FIRST COMMITMENT
TO A STATE HOSPITAL IF THEY'RE
CONVICTED OF A NEW FELONY WHILE
SERVING THEIR INDETERMINATE
TERM IN THE STATE HOSPITAL. SB
TWO FORTY EIGHT PASSED ON
CONSENT OF THE SENATE FLOOR.
AND HAS NO VOTES IN ITS
HISTORY. AND I DON'T WANT YOU
TO MAKE AN EXCEPTION TO THAT
PLEASE SUPPORT IN. THANK IS
LACKING SAY NOTICE KASHER AND
ABATE. WORK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AND VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT ABOUT. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY SIX NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM NINETY
NINE. THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE
HUNDRED. SB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
CORKERY. SENATE BILL TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT BY CENTER LEVEL
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT MR
RODRIGUEZ YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS ARISE
PRESENT SB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
PROTECT THE PROMISE AND PAID
FOR RETIREMENT BENEFITS OF
CALPERS MEMBERS BY MAKING SURE
THAT NO HARM COMES TO RETIRE
RETIREE FOR ANY COLLECTIVELY
BARGAIN PENSIONABLE
COMPENSATION THAT WERE REPORTED
TO THE SYSTEM. THIS MEASURE
RESPONSE TO CASES IN WHICH
CALPERS RETROACTIVELY DEEMED
PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION OF
RETIRED EMPLOYEES AS DISALLOW
MANY RETIREES LIVE ON FIXED
INCOMES AND SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
EXPERIENCE UNEXPECTED CUTS
THROUGH THE BENEFITS AT NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN LONGER AFTER
THEY HAVE RETIRED. SPECIFICALLY
THIS BURST OUT THIS IS A
PROCESS FOR CALPERS AND
EMPLOYERS TO WORK TOGETHER TO
PROTECT RETIREE BENEFITS
MITIGATE RETIREE LOSSES NOW
PROVIDES A MECHANISM TO PREVENT
THESE INCIDENTS FROM EVER
HAPPENING IN THE FIRST PLACE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
REYES RODRIGUEZ SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MY RIVER IS THAT OF A. WELL
CLOSER ALL HOWEVER HIGHS FIFTY
ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE WANT TO GO BACK AND
PICK UP A COUPLE OF MISTER
SANTIAGO'S ITEMS. BEGINNING
WITH FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT
THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT.
SB. THREE SEVENTEEN. IN THE
CORPORATION SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR STERN AND
ACTUALLY IN THE CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE MR SANTIAGO YOU MAIL
THINK OF A SPEAKER SB THREE
SEVENTY IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE THAT WILL ENSURE
INCOMPETENT DEFENDANTS ELIGIBLE
SER FOR SAME SAME TIME SERVE
CREDIT IS GOOD CONDUCT AS ANY
OTHER DEFENDANT. RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU MISS
SANTIAGO SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS OUT OF THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AND VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MR
SANTIAGO YOU HAVE ANOTHER
ADDITIONAL ITEMS THIS IS FILE
ITEM EIGHTY FOUR. SB SEVEN
THIRTY FOUR CORPORATE. SENATE
BILL SEVEN THIRTY FOUR BY
SOONER HUESO AND OTHERS AN
APPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY REDEVELOPMENT MR
SANTIAGO YOU MALE PROTAGONISTS
FIGURE THIS BILL WOULD PROTECT
THE FISCAL SOLVENCY OF CITIES
BY ALLOWING THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO SHE DEBT
ACCRUED TO DEVELOPMENT.
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. FAVOR SANTIAGO SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE. BURKE
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRABLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT.
CLARK WELL. CLOTHES ARE ALL
TIED UP I SIXTY THREE KNOWS
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARAMBULA WE'RE GOING TO
BE MOVING WITHOUT OBJECTION TO
ITEM ONE SIXTEEN SB FIVE THIRTY
NINE FIVE HERTZBERG MISTER
MULLIN WHEN YOU ARE AT THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FIVE THIRTY NINE BY CENTER
HERTZBERG AND OTHERS MACULATUS
TAXATION TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY. THANK YOU
MISTER MULLIN. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS LAST NOVEMBER
CALIFORNIA VOTERS WERE ASKED TO
WEIGH IN ON PROPOSITION
NINETEEN. WHICH ASKED VOTERS TO
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE
CONSTITUTIONAL RULES FOR
PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENT
TRANSFERS IN ORDER TO CORRECT
UNFAIR TAX LOOPHOLES. AND
PROVIDE HOUSING RELIEF FOR
MILLIONS OF SENIORS AND WORKING
FAMILIES. IMPORTANTLY PROP
NINETEEN ALSO PROVIDED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GENERATE
DESPERTELY NEEDED REVENUE FOR
FIRE PROTECTION AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. IN OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. THE
INITIATIVE WAS SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD ARRAY OF GROUPS ACROSS
THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM
INCLUDING THIS LEGISLATIVE
BODY. BY WAY OF LAST YEAR'S ACA
ELEVEN ALTERNATELY APPROVED BY
CALIFORNIA VOTERS. LAST
NOVEMBER. HOWEVER PROP NINETEEN
DID LEAVE A HANDFUL OF
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS CRITICAL
TO ITS PROPER IMPLEMENTATION
AND ADMINISTRATION. COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION REALTORS THE MOST
IMPORTANTLY. ELIGIBLE
HOMEOWNERS WISHING TO SELL OR
TRANSFER THEIR TAX BASE REQUIRE
STATUTORY CLARITY. IN ORDER FOR
HOMEOWNERS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ROBUST HOUSING
MARKET. SB FIVE THIRTY NINE IS
CONSENSUS FOCUS TO MAKE SEVERAL
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO ELIMINATE
REMAINING UNCERTAINTY WITH
PROPOSITION NINETEEN. IT ALSO
ADDS EMERGENCY REGULATION
AUTHORITY FOR THE BE A WAY. TO
DO THE IMPORTANT WORK OF
UPDATING ITS RULES TO AID
TAXPAYERS AND ASSESSORS. THIS
BILL IS REFLECTIVE OF HOURS OF
INTENSE REVIEW BY STAKEHOLDERS
TO ENSURE WE PROBABLY ADDRESS
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS OF PROP
NINETEEN AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GALLAGHER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
THIRTY NINE- THIS MAKES
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATIONS- TO
PROTECT THE INTENT OF
PROPOSITION NINETEEN. INCLUDING
PROVISIONS TO HELP PROTECT THE
INTENT TO PROTECT FAMILY FARMS-
ED TRANSFERS OF FAMILY FARMS IN
PROP NINETEEN TO ENSURE THAT
EACH. PARCEL SO TRANSFER WOULD
HAVE- THE PROTECTIONS- FROM
ADDITIONAL TAXATION TO HELP
PROTECT THE TRANSFER OF THOSE
FAMILY FARMS TO THE NEXT
GENERATION AND ENSURE THAT
THOSE ARE NOT GOING TO BE.
NEGATIVELY AFFECTED AND HAVE TO
ULTIMATELY SELF FAMILY FARMS WE
WANT TO KEEP THOSE GOING STRONG
IN CALIFORNIA AND NOT HAVE ANY
NEGATIVE IMPLICATIONS- AS WAS
THE INTENT. OF THE VOTERS AND
WHAT WAS STATED TO THE VOTERS
IN PROPOSITION NINETEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SEE YOU KNOW THE
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK OF MR
MULLIN I BELIEVE WILL ACCEPT
THAT AS HIS CLOSE WITH THAT THE
COURT LIBERAL. MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE- DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING
THE VOTES I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE UP. SOME
AMENDMENTS THIS IS A FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY FIVE WE'RE GOING TO
JUMP IN FRONT OF ONE NINETY
FIVE. SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
TWO FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS. SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY TWO WITH THE MINUTES BY
SOME MEMBER MAYES. MISTER MASON-ON THE MAMMOTHS I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE PRESENT
AMENDMENTS FOR SB THREE NINETY
TWO THESE MEMBERS PREVENT
CHOPPING OUT ISSUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS MAYES
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE I. SEVENTY
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT
TO PRINTED BACK ON FILE. IN
THIS IS MISS FRIEDMAN FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY TWO THESE ARE
AMENDMENTS MEMBERS FILE ITEM
ONE FORTY TWO S. B. SIXTY THREE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORKERY WITH A MESSAGE SENATE
BILL SIXTY THREE WITH A MEMBERS
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN.
THIS FRIEDMAN ON THE MAMMOTHS.
THANK YOU MISTRESS THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS OF THESE
AMENDMENTS SIMPLY CHAPTER OUT
OF ISSUES WITH ASSEMBLY BILLS I
WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE. ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE DOCTOR BILLS
OUT THE PRINTER BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
ASSEMBLY. CONCURRENCE THIS IS
CAN CURRENT TO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS. WE'RE GOING TO BE
CONCURRING AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. FIRST. WE'RE GOING
TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE PASS A RETAINER
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE THIS IS
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE EIGHTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
FIFTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SALAS AND OTHERS AN APPLICANT
TO TRIBAL GAMING IN THE CLARITY
OF ZERO STICK FACT MEDIALLY.
MISTER MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE PERCENT
EIGHTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN WHICH
WILL RATIFY THE TRIBAL GAMING
COMPACTS. ENTERED INTO BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TWO TRIBES
OF SANTA ROSA INDIAN COMMUNITY
OF THE SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA.
AND THE MIDDLETON RANCHERIA
POMO INDIAN RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. NAME IS SALAS SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLARK WELL
OVERALL. WHAT IS THAT IT ALL
MEMBERS THAT IS ADAMANT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE PRESENTABLE. WELL
CULTURAL TIE THAT I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THE URGENCY I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM FOR
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES AND
ACT WITHIN THE HEALTH CARE
MISTER OF ARTISTS EMAIL BUT-
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN EXPANDS THE AVAILABILITY
OF PRENATAL OR POSTPARTUM
MENTAL HEALTH CARE TO PATIENTS
SEEKING. ASSISTANCE AFTER
EXPERIENCING A MISCARRIAGE OR
STILLBIRTH AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN
THE SENATE WERE MINOR AND
TECHNICAL IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MARTIN SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ZERO ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS
REPRESENTATIVE OF. WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIX AB SEVEN. THE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
OTHERS AND THEY'RE GOING TO
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES
MISTER RODRIGUEZ. THANK A
MISPRINT BERS CENTER MEMBERS
REMOVE OPPOSITION BY CLARIFYING
THE BILL WOULD APPLY TO ALBUM
SOME PLACE RESPOND EMERGENCY
CALLS AND SPECIFY THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENTS WOULD NOT
INTERFERE WITH COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. THIS BILL NOW
ENJOYS SUPPORT FROM LABOR AND
PRIVATE AMBULANCE PROVIDERS ARE
SPECT OUT FOR I WILL. THANK YOU
REYES RODRIGUEZ SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS SENATORS
OUT OF THE- ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. BURKE WELL.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP AT
HIGHS FORTY NINE KNOWS SEVEN
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
SEVEN THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHT.
AB SIXTY THREE. CORPORATE THE
BILL SIXTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS AND OTHERS
MACKLIN TO MARINE RESOURCES.
NORTH YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AT MEMBERS AB
SIXTY THREE IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING IN NATURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THAT.
THANK YOU SPEECH NOR SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL OF
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THEM. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. THIS IS. FILE
ITEM NINE AB SEVENTY CORRECT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AND
OTHERS MACKLIN TO GENE
SYNTHESIS. MISTER CELIS YOU
MAILED ME THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB SEVENTY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE ON AMENDMENTS WERE
MINOR TECHNICAL RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR IVAN. FAMOUS SELSEY
NOTIFICATION OF A CLERK WILL
OFFER THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- THE CLERK WILL FEDERAL TIVER
I SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
THIS IS FILE ITEM TEN AB THREE
TWENTY THREE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
AND OTHERS AND I PLAY THE
HEALTH FACILITIES MISTER KALRA
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS OF THE MEMBERS
TO AB THREE TWENTY THREE A
TECHNICAL ARTICLE AUTHOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON SEVEN AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
MISS KALRA SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. BURKE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. IT IS TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WELL. CLOSE RURAL CHINA TIES
FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWELVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
HOUSE RETAINER PAUL- LEVIN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWELVE EIGHTY
FOUR FOUR SIX CORKERY. SUMITRO
FOR FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MASON ACKLEY TO
ELECTIONS MISTER MACY MAIL I
THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB FOR
SIX IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
ADDRESS CAPTURING OUT CONCERNS
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISMAS SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. WHO'S THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS FURTHER SAID ABOUT HER
WELL. ZERO TELLURIDE'S FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONFERRED IN. THIS IS MISS
CARILLO. FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY CORPORATE A
SINGLE FOR EIGHTY BY SOME
REMEMBER CARILLO AND OTHER
SNACK LEADING TO HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS MISS CARILLO YOUR
MAILBOX THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS- EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENTS REMOVE ALL THE
OPPOSITION TO MAKE EVERYONE
NEUTRAL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK MISCREANT SAY
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. OR CALL THE ROLL. THE
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS VETERANS
AT ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A. THE CLERK WELL. CLOSE
A ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
SIX NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN THIS IS FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN AB FORTY THREE
COVERAGE. ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND ACT WITHIN THE PEACE
OFFICERS MISTER JONES SAWYER
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER
AB FORTY THREE IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE CONCURRENCE SENATE
MEMBERS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE. AB FORTY THREE HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION MEMBERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. RESERVE
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
WELL. CLOSER ROLE TIVER I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE PINKERTON. SESS FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN AB SIX OH THREE CORKERY
WAS THE MIDDLE SIX OH THREE BY
SOME MEMBER MCCARTY AND EQUITY
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT MR MCCARTY
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
SOME TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS ON CONCURRENCE ASK
YOUR ABOUT THINKING. THANK YOU
IS FOR COURTESY NOTICE QUESTION
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THE CEREMONY ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL HOWEVER I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN. FIFTEEN CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
I'M GOING TO HIGHER EDUCATION
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS. MYSTERY
GUEST FEMALE THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKING MEMBERS SB SIX FIFTEEN
OR PROVIDE MINIMUM EMPLOYMENT
RIGHT TO MEDICAL AND DENTAL
RESIDENTS AND INTERNS WHO WORK
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION EMPLOYER I
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE THESE
PROTECTIONS THE SENATE MEMBERS
ARE MONITOR MOVED OPPOSITION.
BY SPECIFYING DISCIPLINARY
ACTION REGARDING TO THE BILL
YOU TO DO THE JOB WOULD NOT BE
IMPACTED I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. WELL
OVER THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS. IS
THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. WELL CLOSE
ROLE TIVER I FIFTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE COULD
COOL CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN AB SIX FORTY
COVERAGE. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY
AND ACT WITHIN THE FOSTER YOUTH
THIS COOLEY YOU MAY OPEN. WELL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ARE RICE IT RESENT AB
SIX FORTY RELATED TO EXTENT OF
FOSTER YOUTH AND FEDERAL
FUNDING. SENATE AMENDMENTS
RELATED TO CHILDREN IN TRIBAL
PLACEMENTS ALSO ADDRESSED
SHEPHERD OUT ISSUES. AB SIX
FORTY WILL HELP DRAW DOWN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR YOUTH AND
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FIRST REFRESH HER AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
MISS COOLEY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OF A- CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. THIRTY TWELVE. CLOSE
A ROLL CALL VOTE I SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THIS IS FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN. AB EIGHT FORTY NINE I
MISS REYES CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AREAS AND OTHER
SNAPPING TO HEALTH FACILITIES
THIS RARE FEMALE BUT THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE PROTECTS THE RIGHTS
OF SENIORS LIVING AND SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. THE BILL IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN TO THE SENATE INSURED
DAMAGES ARE PROPORTIONATE TO
THE SEVERITY OF VIOLATIONS AND
MAKE THE BILL APPLE FROM MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FORWARD. THEY
REMOVE OPPOSITION FROM CHF CMA
THE DOCTORS COMPANY AND
CALCHAMBER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR RIVALS. THANK REDRESS
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRABLE. WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED A VOTE HIGHS
FORTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL. ON FILE ITEM SIXTY
FOUR MS REYES AB. SIX FIVE
FOUR. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. BUT IS
THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
FURTHER SAID ABOUT. WELL. THE
CLOSER ALL. BURKE WELL CLOSER
ROLE TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO ON THE
MEASURE. THE BILL PASSES. BACK
IN THE ORDER ON CONCURRENCE
THIS IS FILE ITEM NINETEEN. AB
NINE FOURTEEN. AND THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KITA WEBER AND OTHERS NOT GOING
THE PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. DR WEBER YOU MAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB IN
NINETEEN FOURTEEN IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL HAD MINOR AMENDMENTS TO
CHANGE AUTHORS THIS BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION HAS RECEIVED. NO NO
VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I AM AB NINE FOURTEEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO OPT WEBER.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
WELL OPEN THE ROLE. THAT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE SENATE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WORKERS OUT OF A.
WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. PASS A
RETAINER FILE ITEM TWENTY. THE
BRIDGE AT FIVE TWENTY ONE AB
NINE FORTY EIGHT. OR FORTY
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE FORTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND
OTHERS NOT QUITE IN THE REAL
ESTATE. MR HOLDING YOUR MAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB NINE FORTY EIGHT IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE FROM THE
SENATE AFTER RECEIVING NEARLY
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
WERE TECHNICAL IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK RIVAL. THANK
MITCHELL HOLDEN SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THOSE ARE THE. ALL MEMBERS OF A
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- HARPSWELL
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS MR
MCCARTY FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
AB. NINE SEVENTY OPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHER SNACK WAITING TO ZONING
MR MCCARTY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS IS A MEASURE
RELATE TO CHARGING STATION
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA SOME TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS RELATING TO THE
TIMELINE OF IMPLEMENTATION THIS
BILL ASK ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CARD. SENIOR
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ESERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. CARDWELL.
CLOSE ROLE TYLER HIGHS FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS ELEVEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
REPORT TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE. EVERY
JUST FIVE TWENTY FOUR AB TEN
TWENTY. SEPARATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS NOT CLEAN
THE HEALTH CARE MS FRIEDMAN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TEN TWENTY
STRENGTHENS THE PROTECTIONS IN
HOSPITAL FOR PER ACT TO ENSURE
THAT PATIENTS IN NEED OF ACCESS
TO THE FINANCIAL SYSTEM TO THE
USER OF THAT HOSPITALS THAT
COLLECTORS AND DEBT BUYERS ALL
PLAY BY THE RULES THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
REMOVED TO THE OPPOSITION OF
THE DEBT COLLECTORS AND DEBT
BUYERS FURTHER CLARIFIED THE
PROCESS FOR PATIENT PATIENT
NOTIFICATION DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OVERSIGHT
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE ACCESS INFORMATION TO
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AND A
TECHNICAL AND CHOP DURING
CHANGES I WOULD URGE AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
FREEMAN CENTER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLICK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
WELL CLOSE ROLE TIED UP I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
R. CONCURRED IN. WHAT A PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM. TWENTY
FIVE. AND PASS TEMPORARILY. ON
FILE ITEM. PASS AND RETAIN
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE A FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX.
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY THREE CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER RAMOS INEQUITY TO
DESERT CONSERVATION. MISTER
ROBERTS EMAIL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY THREE IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE. THIS
BILL RE CREATE A VITAL PROGRAM
WITH THE- WILDLIFE CONSERVATION
BOARD FOCUSED ON FUNDING
PROJECTS WITHIN THIS REGION-
NGOS TRIBES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THE PUBLIC WILL BENEFIT.
FROM THE IMPORTANT CONSERVATION
RECREATION AND RESTORATION
PROJECTS THIS PROGRAM WILL
ENCOURAGE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MYSTERONS
SEINER DISCRETIONARY BASED
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. WHAT
IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. IT IS AT A VOTE. WELL
CLOSER ROLE TELL YOUR EYES
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS TWELVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
FOLLOWING TWENTY SEVEN AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE COVERAGE SOME
OF YOU'LL EVER NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MCCARTY AND OTHER
SNACK WITH FIREARMS MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
IS MY BIPARTISAN FIRE ARMS
TRACING BILL- BACK ON
CONCURRENCE WAS SOME MINOR
AMENDMENTS ASKEY RIVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WAS REGARDING
SAYING THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THAT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THE RIVER
IS THAT OF A- BURKE WELL CLOSER
ALL HI BUT I FIFTY SIX NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
COVERAGE. SOME PEOPLE THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AND ACTING IN A MENTAL
HEALTH RESERVE WHEN YOU MAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT SENATE LANGUAGE
ENSURES THAT CHILDREN ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DR OF.
THANK YOU MR ONE SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL. OUT OF VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. ZERO
FOUR TWELVE CLOSER ALL TYLER I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE IS AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE FIVE
MINUTES RIVAS. THE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US AND OTHERS NOT
GOING TO PRESCHOOL THIS RIVAS
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN ADDRESS OUR
OUR TECHNICAL IN NATURE AND
RESOLVE CHAPTER IN OUT ISSUES
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU REYES RIVAS SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. YOU DESERVE IT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRABLE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY SIX TWO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE CONCURRED IN
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY. AB
FORTINO FIVE GREGORY. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN OH FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AND
ACCORDING TO CONSUMER DEBT.
THIS WICKS EMAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
FORTINO FIVE A MODERNIZE
CURRENT LAW TO BETTER REFLECT
THE DEBT SETTLEMENT INDUSTRIES
PRACTICES. AND IMPROVE
REGULATION DEBT SETTLEMENT
COMPANIES BY ENSURING THAT ALL
THAT SETTLEMENT COMPANIES
OPERATING CALIFORNIA. ARE
COVERED BY CALIFORNIA LAW. I'VE
HAD EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE OPPOSITION AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS HAVE ADDRESSED A
NUMBER OF THEIR CONCERNS THESE
AMENDMENTS HAVE MOVED A FCC. F.
IN SERRA C. D. R. I. IN THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE TO NEUTRAL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS WICKS SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRABLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS FOR. RESERVE A.
WELL CLOSER ALL THE TIME BUT I
FORTY NINE KNOWS FIFTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN AND
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE. FOURTEEN YOU WERE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTEDBY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER REVIVED
OTHERWISE TIME BARRED CLAIMS
AND EXEMPTS SUCH CLAIMS FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CLAIM
PRESENTATION REQUIREMENTS
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
OR TO SPECIFY THE SELF COVERED
BY THIS BILL APPLY ONLY TO
ASSAULTS THAT OCCUR ON OR AFTER
THE PLAINTIFFS EIGHTEENTH
BIRTHDAY. CLEAR FOR THE TIME
FRAME FOR COMMENCING IN ACTION
AND ADDED THAT THE DEFINITION
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT TO SPECIFIED-
PENAL CODE SECTIONS THE BILL
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
WOMAN'S LAWCENTER CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA. THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WICKS
SINGER DISCUSSION DEBATE. WELL
OPEN THE ROLE. ESERVER ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESERVE A. CLERK
WILL CLOSE ROLE. TELL YOUR EYES
FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS FOR CURTAINS THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE CORPORATE
SYMBOL FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE
BIASED MEMORY AS AN ACTOR IN A
HUMAN SERVICES THIS RARE FEMALE
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE
ENSURES IMMIGRANT VICTIMS OF
CRIMES HAVE ACCESS TO THE
CRITICAL SERVICES AND RESOURCES
THEY NEED THE BILL IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
MEMBERS TAKEN SENATE WERE
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING. THE
BILL ENJOYS UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU MS REYES.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVERALL ALL MEMBERS
IS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. HOME MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. IN
THE CLERK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL
YOU WHAT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONSIDERED IN. PASS RETAIN A
FELON THIRTY THREE THIS IS FILE
ITEM THIRTY FOUR. AB FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO. CORRECT SOME PEOPLE
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO BY A SUMMER
MCCARTY AND OTHERS CONNECTED IN
A DRUG TREATMENT. MR CARTER
YOU'RE BUSY TODAY THANK YOU MY
LAST ONE THANK YOU THIS IS MY
DISTRICT BILL HOPE YOU ALL OVER
THE TO DRUG TREATMENT
FACILITIES. SOME TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS WAY TO OVERSIGHT ASK
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AS REGARDS SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ALL CALVET EYES
FIFTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE OF
EMMA CERTAIN CURTAIN PASS
RETAIN A FIVE THIRTY FIVE THIS
IS FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX AB
FIFTEEN SEVENTY IN THE COVERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN SEVENTY
BY THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES IN ACCRA IN THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES MS REVERSE
YOUR MAILBOX THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AND IS THE
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES.
COMMITTEES OMNIBUS BILL WHICH
MAKES NON CONTROVERSIAL
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING CHANGES
TO STATUTES AFFECTING CAL FIRE
THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY AND CAL
RESPECT RECYCLE. THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS REAVIS
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
REZAR TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THEM. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL
CLOSER ALL TADARISE SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS
WORKING CURTAIN. IN THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN AJ ARE
TO BY MR O'DONNELL. CORPORATE
SOON ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION
TO BUY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO COASTAL AND MARINE WATERS
MISTER AT ALL. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARE ASTERS
AND AJ ARE TOO WHICH CALLS ON
CONGRESS AND THE FEDERAL ABOUT
THE FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY TO TAKE ALL
MEASURES NECESSARY TO PREVENT
THE DDT. DUMPING SITE OFF THE
COAST OF LOS ANGELES FROM
FURTHER HARMING OUR OCEANS AND
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDED CO AUTHORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL. SEEING NO DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THE OUT OF COURT
WILL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS
BIRDS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHAT IS THAT ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A CLERK
WILL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT. WE ARE FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE AB SEVENTY TWO THE CARD
FOR ME ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND OTHERS IN
APPLING TO ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. THIS PETRIE-NORRIS
EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB SEVENTY TWO IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
CLARIFYING I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE THAT. THANK YOU SPEECH
IN OUR SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE- THE SERVER.
ALL MEMBERS FOR DESERVE A- WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY. AB ONE HUNDRED
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN AND OTHERS NOT GOING
INTO DRINKING WATER. MR HOLDING
AVAIL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE ALL
FAUCETS AND FIXTURES TO LEECH
AS LITTLE AS POSSIBLE WE HAVE
WORKED WITH INDUSTRY AND I'VE
TAKEN A MINISTER REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
HOLDEN SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR
ALL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL AND TELL
YOU ABOUT I. SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM FORTY
ONE. WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP MR
HOLDEN'S ITEM THIS IS FILE ITEM
FORTY TWO. AB TWO FORTY TWO.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FORTY TWO BY SOME MEMBER HOLDEN
IN ACCRA IN THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE THE SHAREHOLDING MAKE
IT ALL BUT THE SPEAKER THANK
YOU AB TWO FORTY TWO IS A CLEAN
CODE CLEANUP BILL THAT MAKES A
NUMBER OF TECHNICAL CHANGES IN
THE PUBLIC UTILITY CODE
STREAMLINES REPORTING EFFORTS
AT THE CPUC AND ADDS
CLARIFICATION ON ELIGIBILITY TO
ACCESS WILDFIRE FUNDS SENATE
AMENDMENTS FIX THE CHAPTER IN
CONFLICT WITH SB SEVEN FIVE SIX
FROM THE SEESSION. AB TWO FOUR
TWO HAS RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS IN CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
MR HOLDER C. NOTIFICATION OR
DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. IT IS THERE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS WERE DESIRABLE. CLICK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TELL YOU THE
I. SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY THREE.
A. B. TWO SEVEN SEVEN FIVE MS
VALIDATORS. CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VALLADARES AND
OTHERS NOT GOING TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. THIS VALIDATORS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWO SEVEN SEVEN IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE IT
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THAT VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE BURKE WELL. CLOSE
ROLLTIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP. A
COUPLE OF MISTER WARTS ITEMS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM FORTY ONE AB
TWO TO THREE. CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWENTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARD MACLAINE
WILDLIFE MR WARD EMAIL THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND THEN
THAT'S TAKEN IN THE SENATE
REDUCE JAIL TIME FOR THE
POACHING OF THE W. PLANT FROM
ONE YEAR TO SIX MONTHS I ASK
FOR YOUR I. FOR CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MR WARD SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. PRESERVER CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CAN CURTAIN. AND WE ARE NOT
GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR. FIE ITEM FORTY FOURS AB
THREE FORTY. THE CORPORATE
ILLEGAL THREE FORTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD MACKLIN SUIT
FINANCIALLY MR WARD EMAIL THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MINUTES
TAKEN IN THE SENATE OR
CLARIFYING IN NATURE AND AYE
OSCAR AYE IN CONCURRENCE. I
THINK IT WAS. DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
TURNS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
FOR HIS ADVICE. WELL CLOSER
ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FORTY FIVE A. B. FOUR THIRTY.
CORPORATE SYMBOL FOR THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AND
ACCORDING TO DEBT COLLECTION
MISTER GRAYSON AVAILABLE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
FOUR THIRTY IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE MEMBERS
TAKING IN THE CENTER TECHNICAL
CLARIFYING IN NATURE THIS BILL
IS ENJOYED BY PARTISAN
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE. I
THINK IT WAS GRAYSON SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE WELL. ALL
MEMBERS FOR. ROSARIO ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL THE CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED
OUT I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CAN CURTAIN.
WE'RE FILE ITEM FORTY SIX A. B.
FOUR FIFTY THREE. KAKORI SOME
PEOPLE FOR FIFTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND OTHERS BACK LATE IN THE
CIVIL LAW THIS GARCIA YOUR MAIL.
THANK YOU ARE THE AMENDMENTS
ARE TECHNICAL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. DAVIS- CSE
NOTICE KASHER DEBATE. PART
TWELVE OPENER ALL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OF ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SIDE OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS. PARKING
FOR DEBT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FORTY SEVEN AB FOUR SIXTY ONE.
CORKERY SOME PEOPLE FOR SIXTY
ONE BY US THE MEMBER OF THE
APPROVED BY AND OTHERS NOT
CLINIC HOURS THE SURVEY
APPROVAL. THANK YOU MA'AM THANK
YOU MEMBERS MISTER SPEAKER FOR
SIXTY ONE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE. THE SENATE MEMBERS
FOR FURTHER CLARIFY PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL AB FOUR SIXTY ONE
ENTREPRENEURS WHILE THEY GET
BACK INTO BUSINESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IRA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM MARKWELL OPENER ALL.
THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE
ROLE TYLER I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. INPHO OR THIS IS
FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB FIVE
ELEVEN. THE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHE SHE AND
OTHERS BACK LEADING TO
SECURITIES MISTER MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS AB
FIVE ELEVEN IS MY SMALL
BUSINESS EQUITY CROWD FUNDING
BILL IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
PASSED OUT OF THE SIMPLY
SEVENTY EIGHT ZERO PASSED OUT
OF THE SENATE THIRTY SEVEN ZERO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MAHER CG. SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A- WELL OVERALL.
IT IS TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ALL CHAVEZ I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT. THIS IS FILE
ITEM. FORTY NINE EIGHTY FIVE
FOURTEEN. CORRECT ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
REWARD NEGLIGENCE OF A LAW MR
WARD THE AVAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND THEN THAT'S TAKEN
IN THE CENTRE CLARIFYING IN
NATURE AND I ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU RESTORED
SENIOR DISCUSSION OF A CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE VOTE I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
R. CONCURRED IN PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM FIFTY THIS IS FILE
ITEM FIFTY ONE. AB FIVE SEVEN
SIX BY MISTER MAIENSCHEIN
CORPORATE. SOME PEOPLE FIVE
SEVENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS BACK
WITHIN A PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. ASSEMBLY CHAINMAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FIVE SEVENTY SIX IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING THE
NATURE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE BURKE WELL
OVER THE ROLE. IS THERE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS REPRESENTATIVE OF.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE.
WELL CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONVERTED. THIS
IS FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO AB FIVE
NINETY TWO CORKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
ACTUALLY THE FOSTER YOUTH THIS
FRIEDMAN THE AVAIL. THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FIVE
NINETY TWO PROMOTES PLACEMENT
STABILITY FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND
HELP THEM TRANSITION TO
INDEPENDENCE THE MEMBERS ARE
CLARIFYING IN NATURE AND ALSO
RESOLVE CHAPTER IN YOUR SHOES
AND I HEARD AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. BURKE WELLS.
THE CLOSER ROLE. TIED ABOUT I.
SIXTY ONE NO ZERO. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE KEEPING QUORUM
CALL IN PLACE WE HAVE. BUSINESS
THAT REMAINS BEFORE THE
ASSEMBLY TODAY. WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO TAKE UP. A SPECIAL
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY AT THIS
TIME MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
THANK YOU HAVE A RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION AT THIS TIME. TIM IS
CALDERON. MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF GLORIA RENDON. SHE
WAS THE DAUGHTER OF LOS ANGELES
BORN THERE ON FEBRUARY FIRST
NINETEEN FORTY TWO. VIRTUALLY
FROM HER BIRTH SHE WAS A DIE
HARD DODGER FAN. AND A LOYAL
BRUEN. LAST MONTH SHE STAY
GLUED TO YOUR SEAT FOR SIX
HOURS AT THE DODGERS BATTLED
THE PADRES FOR SIXTEEN INNINGS
TO WIN THE GAME. SHE WAS ALSO A
DEVOTED UCLA BASKETBALL FAN
FROM THE GLORY DAYS OF JOHN
WOODEN. BRUINS TO THE TEAM'S
FINAL FOUR LAST SPRING WHEN
UCLA BECAME ONE OF THE ONLY
TEAMS TO GO FROM FIRST FOUR TO
FINAL FOR AN ALMOST UPSET THE
TOP SEEDED GONZAGA BULLDOGS.
HERFATHER DIED WHEN SHE WAS
VERY YOUNG AND THEY GAVE HER
TOUGHNESS AND- DAY SHE CARRIED
WITH HER THROUGHOUT HER LIFE.
GLORIA WAS ALWAYS KIND SELFLESS
GENEROUS AND CONSIDERATE. WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME REMARKABLY
STRONG AND UNFLAPPABLE IN TIMES
OF CRISIS. GLORIA ALWAYS FOUGHT
FOR OTHERS AS MUCH AS SHE
FOUGHT FOR HERSELF AND HER
CHILDREN. IF A WORKER WAS
MISTREATED IN HER PRESENCE. SHE
WOULD STAND UP TO STRANGERS AND
CALL THEM ON IT FOR BEING RUDE.
KEEP IN MIND SHE WAS ONLY FIVE
FEET TALL BUT SHE WAS AS FIERCE
AND TENACIOUS AS ANYONE TWICE
HER SIZE WHEN IT CAME TO HOW
MUCH YOU VALUE DECENCY AND
KINDNESS. SHE TAUGHT HER
CHILDREN TO STAND UP FOR
THEMSELVES. REMINDING HER
DAUGHTERS IN PARTICULAR TO
NEVER ALLOW ANYONE TO BE A
LITTLE BE RATE FOR DISRESPECT
THEM. GLORIA HAD NO PATIENT FOR
RACISTS MISOGYNISTS AND
HOMOPHOBES AND STRUGGLED TO
UNDERSTAND POLITICIANS AND
THEIR SUPPORTERS WHO BUILT
PLATFORMS BASED ON HATE AND
XENOPHOBIA. SHE BELIEVED
EVERYONE HAD A RIGHT TO MARRY
WHOMEVER THEY LOVED. ONCE ONE
OF HER DAUGHTERS YOUNG BEST
FRIENDS CONFIDED IN GLORIA HE
WAS GAY BEFORE HE EVEN TOLD HIS
OWN PARENTS. SHE RESPONDED BY
ASSURING HIM SHE WAS CONFIDENT
HIS PARENTS WOULD BE AFFECTING
OF HIM BUT IF NOT SHE WOULD
ADOPT THEM. NOTHING DEFINED
GLORIA MORE THAN A LOVE AND
DEVOTION SHE HAD FOR HER FAMILY.
SHE MARRIED THE LOVE OF HER
LIFE TOM RENDON IN SEPTEMBER
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR. THIS MONTH
THEY WERE TO CELEBRATE THEIR
FIFTY SEVENTH WEDDING
ANNIVERSARY AND TOM HAD
SECRETLY MADE TRAVEL PLANS.
AFTER ALL THE YEARS THEY WERE
STILL MADLY IN LOVE WITH EACH
OTHER THEY HELD HANDS
CONSTANTLY. THEY COMMONLY
SHOWED EXPRESSION OF THEIR LOVE
FOR ONE ANOTHER. THE DAY BEFORE
HER SUDDEN PASSING TOM TOLD
GLORIA HOW FORTUNATE HE WAS
THAT IT OF ALL THE PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD SHE FELL IN LOVE WITH
HIM. HOURS BEFORE HER HEART
ATTACK HE BOUGHT HER TWO DOZEN
RED ROSES. EVERY MONDAY FOR
THIRTY YEARS GLORIA COOK TO
DINNER IN HER HOME FOR ALL OF
HER FAMILY. ABOVE ALL ELSE IT
WITH HER FAMILY THAT WAS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING IN THE
WORLD TO HER. IN HER HOUSE HE
WERE CARED FOR FED AND
PAMPERED. NONE OF IT EVER FELT
LIKE SHE SAW IT AS HER DUTY.
SHE SIMPLY DERIVED HER OWN
HAPPINESS FROM THE HAPPINESS OF
THOSE AROUND HER. SHE LOVED THE
HOLIDAYS THE MOST BECAUSE IT
MEANT THAT ALL HER LOVED ONES
WOULD CRAM INTO HER HOUSE AND
JUST ENJOY BEING TOGETHER. HER
HEART WAS BIG ENOUGH FOR
EVERYONE. SHE NEVER SAID NO TO
ANY FAVOR ASKED OF HER BY
ANYONE. SHE DID NOT SEE LIVE IS
A FINITE RESOURCE TO BE
PARCELED OUT AND CAREFULLY
GUARDED SHE SO LOVED IS
SOMETHING BIG GREW
EXPONENTIALLY AS SHE WELCOMED
FRIENDS FIANCE'S. IN LAWS AND
GRANDCHILDREN. ANTHONY
CHRISTINE AND LEAH SHE WAS OUR
FIRST AND BEST TEACHER. SHE
TAUGHT THEM TO VALUE OTHERS
ABOVE ALL ELSE AND LAID THE
FOUNDATION FOR THEIR
ACCOMPLISHED LIVES. SHE SPOKE
TO HER CHILDREN EVERY DAY AND
REASSURED THEM OF HER AND
YOU'LL BE IN LOVE. SHE TOOK
PRIDE IN THE FACT THAT HER
CHILDREN WERE INDEPENDENT
ADULTS. BUT NEVER STOPPED
THINKING OF WAYS TO MAKE THEIR
LIVES EASIER. SHE WAS A LOVING
MOTHER IN LAW TO JEFF. JOSEPH
PATRICK IN HANDING AND WELCOME
TO ALL OF THEM AND TO HER
FAMILY AS THOUGH THEY WERE HER
OWN CHILDREN AND TREATED THEM
AS SUCH. SHE AND TOM BECAME
GRANDPARENTS TO SIX JOSHUA
TIMOTHY ASHLEY THOMAS DEVIN AND
VIENNA SHE WAS DEVOTED TO ALL
OF THEM. SHE WAS NO STRANGER TO
THESE CHAMBERS HAVING VISITED
DOZENS OF TIMES. WHENEVER SHE
DID SOMEONE WILL INEVITABLY ASK
IF SHE WAS PROUD OF HER SON.
HER ANSWER WAS THE SAME EACH
TIME I HAVE FOUR CHILDREN AND
I'M EQUALLY PROUD OF ALL OF
THEM. ALTHOUGH SHE WAS
PAINFULLY TAKEN AWAY LAST WEEK
HER FAMILY IS ETERNALLY
GRATEFUL THAT HER HUSBAND AND
ALL HER CHILDREN WERE ABLE TO
SAY GOODBYE. AND TELL HER ONE
LAST TIME THAT THEY LOVED HER.
LARA RENDON'S LOVE KINDNESS
FAIRNESS SELFLESSNESS
GENEROSITY DECENCY AND COURAGE
WILL CONTINUE TO SHAPE
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE LIVES
AND WORK OF HER FAMILY THAT SHE
HELD SO DEAR MEMBERS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY IN MEMORY
OF GLORY RENDON. THANK YOU
MISTER CALDERON. MS RADIUS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I WAS
MENTIONED TO BUY THIS CALDERON.
GLORIA RENDON HAD A FAMILY WHO
ABSOLUTELY LOVED HER WHO ADORED
HER WHO LOOKED UP TO HER. SHE
WAS THEIR MENTOR. I AM EVER SO
GRATEFUL THAT SPEAKER RENDON
WAS ABLE TO RUSHED TO HIS
MOTHER'S SIDE THE BILL FLIGHTS
AVAILABLE HE HAD TO DRIVE DOWN.
AND DROVE DOWN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT TO BE WITH HIS MOTHER
TO HOLD OUR HANDS. AND TO SAY
GOOD HIS GOODBYES. I RECENTLY
WAS SPEAKING WITH THIS TO THE
SPEAKER ABOUT HIS MOTHER IN THE
SAID I REMEMBER THE FIRST TIME
I MET HER I WAS MY FIRST YEAR.
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND IT WAS FOR
A SIGNING. OF A BILL. I SAID
SHE WAS SO PROUD OF YOU. AND
YOU WERE SO PROTECTIVE OF HER
YOU HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT
SERGEANTS WERE TAKING CARE OF
HER. HE SAID. SHE WAS PROUD OF
ME BUT SHE WASN'T THERE BECAUSE
OF ME SHE WAS THERE BECAUSE
GOVERNOR BROWN WAS GOING TO BE
THERE. AND HE WAS SIGNING THIS
BILL. WE DO WANT TO LET THE
SPEAKER KNOW. THE CHEST AS HIS
MOTHER HAD A WONDERFUL FAMILY
THAT LOVED HER AND ADORED HER.
WE WANT THE SPEAKER TO KNOW
THAT HE HAS A FAMILY HERE. IN
THE CHAMBER. THAT WE WILL BE
HERE WE WILL SUPPORT HIM IN ANY
WAY. THAT HE NEEDS. FOR HIMSELF.
HIS FAMILY. AND THE REST OF THE
REST OF THE FAMILY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS REYES MISTER
GIBSON YOU TOO ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I ALSO RISE TO LEND
MY VOICE IS WITH THOSE WHO'VE
TALKED ABOUT A GLORIA RENDON- I
AM REMINDED NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE
CERTAIN THINGS IN COMMON
BECAUSE WE BOTH LOVE THE
DODGERS- WE LOVE THEM AND WE
WATCH GAMES OF THE DODGERS BUT
ALSO I'M REMINDED THAT. SHE
ABSOLUTELY- EVERY TIME SHE CAME
TO THE FLOOR HER HUSBAND. WAS
INSEPARABLE. THEY ALWAYS ALWAYS
SAW THEM HOLDING EACH OTHER'S
HANDS. AND WHEN THE SPEAKER
WAS. SWORN IN AS SPEAKER- I SAW
HER LIGHT UP LIKE A CHRISTMAS
TREE HOW PROUD SHE WAS AND I'M
SURE IS NOT ONLY WAS SHE PROUD
OF NOT ONLY HIM. BUT HER ENTIRE
FAMILY AND ME IN THE SPEAKER WE
SHARE SOMETHING IN COMMON- NOT
ONLY ON LOVE THIS SERVICE BUT
ALSO- WE HAVE THREE SISTERS AND
WE'RE THE ONLY BOY. I ALSO WANT
TO MAKE MENTION. OF THAT A FEW
DAYS AGO MY MOTHER MADE IT MAY
TWENTY YEARS THAT MY MOTHER
PASSED AWAY- AND IT SEEMS LIKE
IT WAS JUST YESTERDAY THAT SHE
PASSED. AND I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU HAS TO
HAVE YOUR MOTHER TO DO ME A
FAVOR. TO MAKE A CALL SEND A
TEXT. AND TELL YOUR MOTHER. HOW
MUCH SHE MEANS TO YOU. HOW
IMPORTANT SHE IS. BECAUSE YOU
NEVER UNDERSTAND. WHEN THAT
PRECIOUS JEWEL HAS BEEN TAKEN
AWAY SO MY PRAYERS IS WITH THE
RENDON FAMILY. THAT GOT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE THE WIND BENEATH
HIS WINGS THEIR WINGS. AND THAT
HE WILL WIPE AWAY EVERY TEAR.
FROM YOUR EYE AND GIVE YOU
COMFORT AND PEACE. THANK YOU
MISTER GIBSON. AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS. WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING BACK TO THE CONCURRENCE
FILE. CONTINUE WITH THE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE HOUSE.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM. FIFTY THREE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE NINETY NINE.
IN THE CORPORATE SYMBOL FIVE
NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER AND ACT IN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS MISTER JONES
SAWYER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB FIVE NINE NINE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
THE SENATE FIX DRAFTING ERRORS
AND ALIGN IT WITH THE TIMELINES
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
MEMBERS EXPECT LAST REVIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER SIR SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS OF
OUR THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR AB SEVEN SIXTY FOUR
CORPORATE. SOME PEOPLE SEVEN
SIXTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES PHONETICALLY TO
CONTEMPT OF COURT. CERVANTES
FEMALE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB SEVEN SIX FOUR
CLOSES A LOOPHOLE THREATENING
THE SAFETY OR SURVIVORS BY
ADDING CONTACT OVER SOCIAL
MEDIA FOR ELECTRONIC MEANS THE
LIST OF PROHIBITED FORMS OF
ACTIVITY FOR PROTECTIVE ORDERS
FOR CONVICTED STALKERS. I
MEMBERS TAKEN SENATE WERE MINOR
AND CLARIFYING IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
FANTASTIC SENIOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. BURKE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL FOUR ZERO
TITLEIST FIFTY NINE TWO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS WORKING
CURTAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
FIVE AB EIGHT FORTY THREE.
COVERING SYMBOL EIGHT FORTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND ACCORDING TO
ENERGY MS AGUIAR-CURRY EMAIL
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER
A. B. A. FORTY THREE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
THE SENATE FOR THE STREAMLINED
CCA'S PARTICIPATION IN THE
PROGRAM. WHICH WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
WORKLOAD OF THE P. YOU SEE ON
THE PROGRAM AS THEY CAN USE THE
EXISTING PROGRAM AND
REGULATIONS CURRENTLY USED BY-
USE WHEN THEY SEE CO TWO SHOULD
ASSOCIATE CHOOSES TO
PARTICIPATE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR FOR A VOTE. I SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS HER
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
THOSE ARE ALL TIED AYE FIFTY
SIX NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS-
KING CURTIS. HIS FILE ITEM
FIFTY SIX A. B. NINE FORTY FIVE
COOKERY. SOME PEOPLE NINE FORTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROMMEL'S AND OTHER RESPECTED IN
THE PEOPLE'S MISTER ROBERTS HE
MAY OPEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB NINE FOUR
FIVE IS BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE. THIS BILL
ESTABLISH A TAMIL TEN MEMBER
TASK FORCE CONVENED BY THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION-
TO AGGRESSIVELY AND MAKE SURE
THAT EXISTING LAW RELATES TO
WEARING TRADITIONAL TRIBAL
REGALIA AS AN ADORNMENTS AT
SCHOOL GRADUATION CEREMONIES I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU RESTAURANTS SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ADDED THE.
WELL CLOSE AROUND TELLURIDE'S
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IT.
PASS RETAIN A FILE OUT OF FIFTY
SEVEN THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
EIGHT AB TWELVE HUNDRED
CORPORATE SYMBOL TWELVE HUNDRED
BY SIMPLY REVERTING AND OTHERS
BACK LATER PRODUCT SAFETY MR
KING EMAIL BUT I THINK IT
SPEAKER AB TWELVE HUNDRED IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE BILL
WILL PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
RESIDENCE. IN ENVIRONMENT BY
REDUCING HUMAN EXPOSURE TO AN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINATION
FROM P. THOUSAND OTHER
HAZARDOUS CHEMICALS. SEVEN
MINUTES BY THE TECHNICAL
CHANGES THAT REMOVED OPPOSITION
FROM CALCHAMBER CMT A THE
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL THE
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. AND OTHER INDUSTRY
GROUPS THE B. TWELVE HUNDRED C.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THE SENATE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER HE
NOTICED DEBATE. CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS FELT THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL. CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FORTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY
NINE AB TWELVE FIFTY. THE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY WILL
TWELVE FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AND ACTING IN THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES MISTER
CALDERON EMAIL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWELVE FIFTY
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE SENATE
AMENDMENTS EXTEND THE TIMELINE
FOR THE REVIEW OF WATER SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATIONS AND SPECIFY THAT
SYSTEMS IDENTIFIED AS FAILING
OR AT RISK OF FAILING OUR
PRAYER I OUR TIES FOR REVIEW.
THIS BILL HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION AND HIS RECEIVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. YEAH THANK THIS CALDERON
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. CARP
WELL OVERALL. ZERO ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AND ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. CLARK WELL
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS RECORD IN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY. AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN CORKERY. SOME
PEOPLE THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
OTHERS NOT QUITE IN THE BILL
MISTER JONES SAWYER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE SENATE
MEMBERS PROVIDE FIRST OF ITS
KIND SIX CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
TO IMMIGRANT FAMILIES ASSESSING
BONDS TO SEEK RELEASE FROM
DETENTION SET FACILITIES THIS
BILL HAS GAINED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
RESTAURANTS WHERE SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THAT
A VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE
CALVET EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
NINE E. TO ALLOW FOR MANAGERS
TO TAKE UP FLOOR AMENDMENTS
AFTER THE DEADLINE ON TH
FOLLOWING BILLS I DON'T WANT TO
WAIT SB THREE EIGHTY ONE
PORTANTINO BY RUBIO. ITEM ONE
FIFTY FOUR SB THREE OH SIX PAM
BUY LOW AND ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO
SB FOUR TWENTY THREE STERN BY
MORE TO G. MR FOR WITHHOLDING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT US ROLL CALL
VOTE. THANK YOU ACT FOR OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL THE VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE ON SUSPENDING THE RULE.
THIS RACE IS ASKING FOR AYE
VOTE MR FLOOR IS ASKING FOR
NOVA. ALL THE FOOD CRITICIZED
TO VOTE. ON SUSPENDING THE RULE
MISTER MISS RACES ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MISTER FLORA IS ASKING
FOR AN OF A.
PARKOUR CLOSER
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE HIGHS
FORTY FIVE NO SEVENTEEN. THE
ROLE IS SUSPENDED. REYES I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RESCINDED THE ACTION WERE BY ON
SEPTEMBER FIRST SB SIXTY EIGHT
BECKER WAS READ THE THIRD TIME
AND PASSED TO THE SENATE.
TRANSACTION WE'RE GONNA. I
WOULD I MOVE TO SUSPEND THE
RULES TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO TO TAKE UP SB SIXTY
EIGHT BECKER TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADOPTING CHAPTER
RING OUT AMENDMENTS WITH THE
FLOOR WE WILL HOLD YOU KNOW
SINCE THE NATURAL COLOR THANK
YOU CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL.
OVER FIRE TO VOTE THIS IS FOR.
THE RULES MISS REYES ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE MISTER FLORA IS
ASKING FOR AN OF A- ALL THOSE
VOTE IT. TO VOTE MISS FRANCE IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER
FLORES ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. OR
CALL CLOSER ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTES HIGHS FORTY THREE NO
SEVENTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WILL GOING TO MOVE TO THE
SECOND DAY CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR AND
BEFORE WE VOTE WE WILL FIRST
TAKE UP THE RESOLUTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ADDING CO AUTHORS.
WILL READ THE RESOLUTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SO THE CURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE AWAIT BY SOME
MEMORABLE THE RANKINGS ON THE
STRUCTURE TO LATINA EQUAL PAY
DAY HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTY
TWO BY SOME MEMBER GAVE A
RELATIVE TO JEWISH HIGH
HIGHWAYS. HOUSE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY THREE BY SOME MIRACLE
WHEN WELL IT'S OF TO REPUBLIC
OF VIETNAM ON HOUSE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY FIVE BY SOME MEMBER
PATTERSON RATHER TO COURT
OPTION AND PERMANENCY MOUTH
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY FIVE BY CENTRE TODD- AND
OTHER STRUCTURE TO BREAST
FEEDING AWARENESS MONTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY SIX BY CENTER
MELENDEZ AND OTHER SORTS OF
BLOOD CANCER AND BLOOD DONATION
AWARENESS SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HER TADO RELATIVE TO
RUNAWAY AND HOMELESS YOUTH
PREVENTION MONTH. AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY
EIGHT BY CENTER HER TADO AND.
OTHERS RELATIVE TO ONE HEALTH
DAY. THE CARD FOR NOW OPEN THE
ROLE TO. I DON'T RECALL LAW TO
THE REST. MEMBERS THIS VOTED
FOR HELLO AUTHORS THE VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. IF YOU WISH TO
ADD ON A COUPLE TO RESUME ON
CAN PLEASE NOW. ALL THOSE
VOTERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. HER
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE
SIXTY ONE CO AUTHORS WILL MOVE
TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DOES ANY MEMBER WHICH
TO PULL AN ITEM FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING
NONTECHNICAL READ THE SECOND
EXAM CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE OH
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN
RELATIVE TO A SISTER STATE
RELATIONSHIP WITH FROM JOB
POCKETS ON. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE- ALL THE
MOVEMENT IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE
VOTES I. SIXTY THREE NINE ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE OH EIGHT I FIFTY
THREE OH ZERO POUNDS WAS LUCIEN
SEVENTY TWO I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO CONSTITUTION SEVENTY THREE
I FIFTY THREE NO ZERO POUNDS
WAS LUCIEN SEVENTY FIVE I THINK
THE THREE NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FIFTY
FIVE. FIFTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY SIX SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
FIFTY SEVEN FIVE SIXTY THREE
NINE ZERO INCIDENT THE CURRENT
RESOLUTION FIFTY FIVE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO.
MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO. TAKE UP A FEW BILL
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS WE
ARE GOING TO BEGIN WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE TO SB SIXTY
EIGHT CORE CORE READ. SENATE
BILL SIXTY EIGHT WITH A WOMEN'S
BY SOME MEMBER CARILLO. PHONE
NUMBER FOR YOU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR BECKER I RISE TO
PRESENT. AWARDS S. B. SIXTY
EIGHT. OTHER CHANGES SB SIXTY
CHANGES A SECTION OF CODE THAT
WAS ALREADY AMENDED BY ONE OF
OUR BUDGET TRAILER BILLS THE
CHANGES IN SB SIXTY EIGHT ARE
UNRELATED TO THE CHANGES IN THE
TRAILER BILL BUT THIS AMENDMENT
IS A NEEDED FIX. FOR A CONFLICT
IN. THE CODE SECTION AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CAREER
SEEING NOVEMBER'S WAS TO
DISCUSS THE MEASURE THE CARPOOL
OPEN THE ROLE ALL THOSE WHO.
HELLO OKAY WE'LL TAKE A VOICE
HEARD ON THE SIDE OF ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR. AND SB SIXTY EIGHT
SAY I'M- ALL THOSE OPPOSED TO
THE MEMBERS A NAME THE EYES
HAVE IT THE MEMBERSARE ADOPTED
THE BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND
BACK ON FILE. NEXT WE'LL MOVE
TO ITEM ONE FIFTY FOUR SB THREE
OR SIX CORKERY. SENATE BILL
THREE OH SIX LIMITS BIASED
MEMBER BELOW. NUMBER WELL YOU
MAY OPEN FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS JUST FIGURING COLLEAGUES
THIS IS HERE FOR A MOMENT SB
THREES OR WHATEVER SO I FAST
PRIVATE. THANK YOU MR LOW.
SEEING WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THE PERSON NAME
THE EYES HAVE IT. THE MEMBERS
ARE ADOPTED THE BILL OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE. WILL
NEXT TAKE UP ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO
SB FOUR TWENTY THREE FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS CORAL
REEF SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY
THREE WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MURATSUCHI. SUMMARY
FIFTY YOU MAY OPEN PURPOSE
SEVEN MINUTES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M PRESENTING AMENDMENTS
REQUESTED BY THE AUTHOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE IPHONE.
THANK YOU MISTER MOORE THIRTEEN
SEEING NOBODY ELSE WISHING TO
DISCUSS THE AMENDMENTS WE WILL
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALTHOUGH THE PERSON
NAME. THE EYES HAVE IT THE
MANAGER DR THE BILL'S OUT
DIFFERENT AND BACK ON FILE. WE
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE OH
EIGHT SB THREE EIGHTY ONE FOR
PURPOSES OF MEMBERS CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY
ONE OF THE MEMBERS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO SOME OF A RUBIO
YOU MAY OPEN YOUR MOMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
AMENDMENTS FOR SB THREE EIGHTY
ONE ARE IN COORDINATION WITH
CALTRANS TO AND IMPLEMENT
STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR- I VOTE
FOR YOUR ARTICLE. THANK HIM
ISRAEL SEEING NO OTHER. MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM
OR WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL THE PERSON NAY.
GUYS HAVEN'T THE MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED THE BILL WITHOUT THE
PRINT AND BACK ON FILE.
MEMBERS
I AM ORDERING THE DEATHS TO BE
HELD OPEN THIS EVENING TO
PROCESS BUDGET RELATED BUSINESS.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
COURT CALL WILL BE LIFTED. AND
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE A
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
I
DID. ABOUT CHANGE FONG FILE
ITEM TEN AB THREE TWO THREE
FROM I'D SAY NOT VERY. BOTH
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY
THREE I TO NOT VOTING. MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO OUR PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED THE GERMANS IN MEMORY
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS FOR YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN MEMORY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN YOUR RECOGNIZE HERE DOES
FOR YOUR GOVERNMENT MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE REQUESTED
WE CHURN IN THE MEMORY OF LONG
TIME SAN MATTEO COUNTY ACTIVIST
AND LEADER RUTH NAYLOR. AFTER
DEVOTING HER ENTIRE ADULT LIFE
TO BETTERING HER COMMUNITY AND
SAN MATTEO RUTH PASSED AWAY
PEACEFULLY ON JULY TWELFTH AT
THE AGE OF NINETY NINE. UPON
RECEIVING A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
FROM THE COLLEGE OF. THE CITY
COLLEGE OF NEW YORK. AND THEN A
MASTER OF ARTS IN EDUCATION
FROM AND WHY YOU. RUTH AND HER
HUSBAND HAD BEEN MOVED TO SAN
MATTEO NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT
WHERE SHE IMMEDIATELY JOINED
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS AND
SHORTLY THEREAFTER BECAME THE
PRESIDENT. OF THE SAN MATTEO
LEAGUE. WITH THE CAME A
PROMINENT ACTIVISTS FIGHTING
FOR QUALITY EDUCATION
THROUGHOUT SAN MATEO COUNTY.
SHE WAS ELECTED TO THE SAN
MATEO CITY ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
BOARD IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE.
WHERE SHE SERVED TEN YEARS
ENSURE PERSON FOR THREE.
ALONGSIDE ACTIVISTS ELLER
CURRY. RUTH HELPED SPEARHEAD
THE FIRST INTEGRATED SCHOOLS IN
THE CITY. REPEL THE MYRIAD OF
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS. AS AN
EDUCATION ADVOCATE INCLUDING
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY EDUCATION
FOR KENYATTA COLLEGE IN REDWOOD
CITY AND SAM THE SAN MATTEO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT. SHE
IS A TRUSTEE ON THE CITY
LIBRARY BOARD. TRUSTEE OF THE
MILLS PENINSULA HOSPITAL BOARD
SHE WAS CHAIR OF THE FRIENDS OF
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE ON WOMEN
A BOARD MEMBER. OF THE WOMEN'S
CENTER OF SAN MATEO COUNTY AND
CHAIR OF THE SENATE HERE
PERFORMING ARTS CENTER. RUTH'S
HARD WORK IN ACTIVISM WAS
RECOGNIZED THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITY. SHE RECEIVED A
COMMUNITY SERVICES AWARD FROM
THE JAPANESE AMERICAN CITIZENS
LEAGUE. THE SAN MATTEO
ELEMENTARY TEACHERS. THE
ASSOCIATION COMMUNITY SERVICES
AWARD. HE ADDED THE GIRLS CLUB
OF MID PENINSULA COMMUNITY
SERVICES AWARD. AND THE- THEY
HAD DOGO CERTIFICATE OF
APPRECIATION FOR WORK RELATED
TO THE HUMAN RIGHTS AND
EDUCATION OF HISPANIC ADULTS
AND CHILDREN WHICH WAS AWARDED
TO HER BY THE MINORITY PARENTS
AND STUDENTS. OF THE SAN MATTEO
COUNTY SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
COUNTY WIDE SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR
A LONG A DEVOTED SERVICES TO
THE YOUTH OF SAN MATTEO AND
DEDICATED SERVICE TO THE
INTEGRATED LEARNING PROCESS.
RUTH IS SURVIVED BY HER SONS
DAVID MICHAEL NAGLER AND OUR
GRANDCHILDREN DREW JULIAN
MARIELLE ERIC AND SEAN. RUTH
WAS A PIONEERING ADVOCATE FOR
WOMEN'S VOICES BEING PROPERLY
REPRESENTED ON GOVERNING BODIES
AND SHE'S INSPIRED GENERATIONS
TO PUBLIC SERVICE IN UR COUNTY
HER SON MICHAEL SAID BEING HER
PRESENT IN HER PRESENCE WAS
QUOTE. LIKE HANGING OUT IN AN
EXCITING DEMOCRATIC POSSIBILITY
HER ABSENCE WILL BE FELT
THROUGHOUT SAN MATEO COUNTY AND
I ASK THAT WE HONOR HER TODAY
BY ADJOURNING IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS YOU'RE
RECOGNIZING YOUR DOES FOR YOUR
PURPOSE OF A ADJOURNMENT MEMORY.
AND I RISE ARE THIS AFTERNOON
ON BEHALF OF THE THIRTY THE
SENATE DISTRICT. IN HONOR OF
ALFRED THE DIAZ INFANTE WHO
PASSED AWAY SUDDENLY EARLIER
THIS MONTH. AND ALFORD WAS
PRESIDENCY CEO OF CHI SPA THE
LARGEST PRIVATE NONPROFIT
HOUSING DEVELOPER BASED IN THE
COUNTY MONTEREY IN THE REGION I
REPRESENT IN THE CALIFORNIA.
EMBLEY A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF-
THE COUNTY MONTEREY AND SALINAS
OFFERED WAS ONE OF THE FINEST
LEADERS ARE ON THE CENTRAL
COAST. I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING WITH ALFRED SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF MY CAREER ON ON
HOUSING AND OTHER ISSUES
AFFECTING OUR UNDERSERVED. SOME
COMMUNITIES ARE MOST HORRIBLE
RESIDENTS AND FAMILIES. WE
SHARE MANY THE SAME VALUES WE
BOTH GREW UP IN A FAMILY OF
FARMWORKERS AND WE SAW FIRST
HAND THE TOUGH- SOME CONDITIONS
THAT THIS COMMUNITY FACES. BUT
WHAT MADE ALFRED. THE SPECIAL
LEADER WAS HIS COMMITMENT HIS
DETERMINATION TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR THE PEOPLE AND
FAMILIES THAT NEEDED IT MOST.
FOR TWENTY FOUR YEARS AS
PRESIDENT CEO OF CHI SPA
OPERATED. HE WAS DEDICATED TO
ENRICHING AND IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
FARMWORKERS THE HOMELESS LOW
WAGE EARNERS THOSE LIVING IN
POVERTY. HE SPOKE ABOUT DOING
OUR PART TO MEET THEIR
ESSENTIAL HUMAN CULTURAL AND
THE COMMUNITY NEEDS WHICH
INCLUDED SAFE AND DIGNIFIED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. HIS
EFFORTS. THEY DIRECTLY LED TO
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THOUSANDS
THOUSANDS OF HOUSING UNITS THAT
TRANSFORM THE LIVES OF
COUNTLESS LOCAL FAMILIES. BUT
HIS LEGACY EXTENDS FAR BEYOND
HOUSING. ALFRED HE WAS. HE WAS
COMMITTED TO SERVE IN THE
COMMUNITY RELATED TO EDUCATION
TO HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT HE SERVED ON THE
SLING THIS REGIONAL SPORTS
AUTHORITY. AND ALSO ON THE BIG
SUR LAND TRUST BOARD WHICH-
WORK TO RESTORE KERR LAKE AND
BRING SOME. SOME RESIDENTS OF
THE SALINAS VALLEY A LARGE
CENTRAL PARK. THERE ARE JUST
SOME OF THE WAYS THAT THAT THAT
OFFERS LEGACY WILL LIVE ON IN.
IN ARE A DISTRICT IN IN OUR OUR
COMMUNITY BUT UNDOUBTABLY HIS
LOSS WILL BE FELT FOR YEARS TO
COME WE ARE ALL MUCH BETTER OFF
FOR HAVING KNOWN HIM AND HAVING
LEARNED FROM HIM MY HEART GOES
OUT TO THE DS IN FRONT THE
FAMILY. AND ART AND ART AND IN
OUR ENTIRE DISTRICT AS AS WE
MOURN OFFERS LOS MAY WE ALL
WORK TO LIVE UP TO HIS LEGACY.
WITH THAT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISTER
RIVERS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER COURT
WE ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS HE WHICH IS
WITH A HEAVY HEART THAT THEY
ASKED WE REDUCE CHURN IN THE
MEMORY OF THE BURKE CHAU
GIOVANNI MENDEZ FOR NOW. WHO IS
THE OLDER BROTHER OF MY
DISTRICT DIRECTOR AND THEREFORE
AN EXTENSION OF MY T. GIOVANNI
WAS A DEVOTED FATHER AND
HUSBAND AND A LOVING SON AND
BROTHER. HE GREW UP IN
GUADALAJARA MEXICO AN
IMPOVERISHED AREA WERE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES WERE
SLIM BUT DESPITE THE HURDLES
LIFE THROUGH ADDED HE WAS
DETERMINED TO OVERCOME
ADVERSITY. HE PURSUED A CAREER
IN LAW HE SAID THERE WERE TOO
MANY INJUSTICES COMMITTED
AGAINST INSTANCE INNOCENT
PEOPLE AT THE HANDS OF A BROKEN
LEGAL SYSTEM. HE IS THE FIRST
LAWYER IN THIS FAMILY HE
DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO HELPING
PEOPLE WITH SEVERAL MATTERS.
FOUGHT FOR JUSTICE FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS AND ADVOCATED
FOR THE WELFARE OF CHILDREN IN
UNSAFE ENVIRONMENTS. GIOVANNI
ALSO KNEW WE WANTED TO HELP
PEOPLE. HE WOULD EVEN TAKE ON
PRO BONO CASES FOR FRIENDS
FAMILY AND PEOPLE WHO COULD NOT
AFFORD A LAWYER. GIOVANNI'S
GENEROSITY KNEW NO BOUNDS HIS
FRIENDS OR NEIGHBOURS REMEMBER
HIM AS GOOD MAN WHO IS ALWAYS
HAPPY SMILING TELLING JOKES AND
MAKING PEOPLE LAUGH. HIS
PASSING WAS SUDDEN AND HE WILL
BE GREATLY MISSED BY ALL THAT
KNEW HIM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DR PARK. SIMMER HOLDING YOUR
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF
DR TRUDELL SKINNER. PERSON WHO
HAS HAD A TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON
THE LIVES OF HUNDREDS OF
STUDENTS AND ADULTS AND
PASADENA AND ALTADENA. SHE WAS
AN EDUCATOR BY TRADE WOULD BE
AN ADVOCATE FOR THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS WAS HER
PASSION. HER GOAL WAS TO BREAK
DOWN BARRIERS THAT PREVENTED
EQUAL ACCESS TO QUALITY
EDUCATION. AND ALSO CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS TO TAKE CHALLENGING
COURSES THAT PUSH THEM TO THE
NEXT LEVEL. SHE SERVED AS
PRINCIPAL OF BLAIR HIGH SCHOOL
IN PASADENA FOR SIX YEARS WHERE
SHE LED IT TO THE HIGH HONOR
BEING NAMED A CALIFORNIA
DISTINGUISHED SCHOOL. SHE WENT
ON TO SERVE IN ADMINISTRATIVE
CAPACITIES AS THE PASSING
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
QUALITY COORDINATOR AND
COORDINATOR OF THE OFFICE OF
ENROLLMENT RECORDS AND PERMITS.
SHE WAS RECENTLY PROMOTED TO
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF T. K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS. IN OUR HOMETOWN OF EL
TO DENA SHE WAS A LEADER IN THE
COMMUNITY AS THE FIRST LADY THE
METROPOLITAN BAPTIST CHURCH AND
OUT TO DINNER WHERE HER HUSBAND
DR TYRONE SKINNER. IS SENIOR
PASTOR. SHE WAS RECOGNIZED AS A
WOMAN OF ACHIEVEMENT BY THE
PASADENA JOURNAL. BESIDES THEIR
PROFESSIONAL ACHIEVEMENTS IN
COMMUNITY ACCOLADES FOR
INTELLIGENCE COMPASSION AND
PERSONALITY MAJOR DEL OUTSIZED
POSITIVE FORCE. FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND HER SPHERE OF
INFLUENCE. SHE IS SURVIVED BY
HER HUSBAND DR PASTOR TYRONE
SKINNER. AND HER CHILDREN
TRINITY AND TYLER. I WISH TO
ADJOURN IN THEIR MEMORY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MR HOLDEN MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DEATH TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER EIGHTH
FLOOR SESSION AT TEN AM.
THURSDAY SEPTEMBER NINTH FLOOR
SESSION AT TEN AM. FRIDAY
SEPTEMBER TENTH FLOOR SESSION
AT TEN AM. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING IMPACT WILL BE PASSED
RETAINED ALL NOTIONS OF THE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER BENNETT MOVES MISTER
NAZARIAN SECONDS THAT THE HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
WEDNESDAY SEPTEMBER EIGHTH AT
TEN AM. CORACLE IS LIFTED.
OKAY
VOTE CHANGES STEVEN CHOI ITEM
NUMBER. TEN EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
THREE NORTH TOTAL NOT FORTY.
SOME CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOI ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY
THREE NO TO NOT VOTING. SECOND
ONE SO FILE NUMBER TWENTY SIX
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE. NO TO
NOT FORTY CHOI ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE NO TO
ANOTHER.